So, as we saw last week before we
start to talk about the produce,
the materials and the holiness code,
as we saw last week,
the covenant ceremony at Sinai included
Gods announcement of and Israel's
agreement to certain
continental stipulations.
So exodus 24 verses three
and four, describe this, uh,
agreement as follows.
Moses went and repeated to the people
all the commands of the Lord and all the
rules and all the people answered with
one voice saying all the things that the
Lord has commanded we will do.
And Moses then wrote down
all the commands of the Lord.
So the Covenant concluded at
Sinai is the climactic moment, uh,
in the pentitude will narrative.
And it came to be viewed as the initiation
of God's articulation of the laws and
rules and ordinances and instruction
by which the ancient Israelites were to
live.
And so later edit editors consequently
inserted lock collections from later
times and circles into the story of
Israel's meeting with God at Sinai and
Subsequent Sojourn in the wilderness.
This was done in order to lend these
collections and air of high antiquity and
to give them divine sponsorship.
The conclusion of Biblical scholarship
is that a number of separate bodies of
law have gravitated to the story of the
40 year period of Israel's formation
into a people. So that's the period
of the Covenant at Mount Sinai.
And then the journey
towards the promised land.
All Israelite law is represented in the
biblical account as having issued from
that time, that 40 year period
of intimate contact with,
between God and Israel. So a,
on your handout, I've given um,
a division,
a rough division of the different
legal collections that we have in the
pentitude.
Um,
the laws that scholars will often refer
to as the Jie laws since they sort of
are introduced by that narrative.
Some people think it's best to just think
of these as separate legal collections,
but those occur in exodus and so
they're 10, they tend to be dated 10th,
ninth century in their written form.
The laws of the priest,
the material are mostly going to be
found in Leviticus and numbers. Um,
and those will be formulated somewhere
from the eighth to the sixth century,
same period of time. Roughly.
We have the laws of D,
which are found obviously in Deuteronomy,
but these sources themselves are clearly
drawing upon much older traditions.
Some of the individual laws
are clearly quite ancient.
They have a great deal in common with
ancient near eastern legal traditions
generally of the second millennium,
the laws of exodus, for example.
Some of them bear such similarity to
the code of Hammurabi that we can really
assume that they are drawing
upon a common legal heritage,
a Canaanite law,
what would have been known as a,
as a legal tradition in in Canaan,
so whatever their actual origin.
However,
the Bible represents these materials
as having been given at Sinai or during
that 40 year period after, so given
at, now this is on your sheet,
you have the deck, a log, not very
well translated as the 10 commandments.
We'll come back to that covenant code,
so that's the chunk of material,
three chapters and exodus.
Then we have a small passage
referred to as a ritual deck log.
We'll come back to that.
You have priestly legislation a little
bit in exodus about the cult, obviously.
Then on into Leviticus and some numbers
and according to the biblical narrative,
then the following materials were given
in the 40 years after Sinai as the
Israelites are encamped in the wilderness
on their journey toward the land of
Israel.
So those are presented as supplements
in numbers but also the Deuteron due to
anomic code. Let's talk a little
bit now about the deck log.
It was this scholar by the name
of Alt, a l t, Albrecht alt
German scholar who examined the illegal
material of the Bible in general and he
noticed that there were
really two forms of law. Yeah.
Are these things I forgot to write down.
There's conditional conditional
law and [inaudible] law.
Conditional Law is case lock has with
stick law and then there's absolute or APP
apoplectic law. So Kacie with
stick. He noticed these two forms.
Um,
Cassie was stick law is the common form
of law that that law is the common form
that law takes in the ancient near east.
And you've seen it in the code of
Hammurabi. It has a characteristic.
If then pattern Cassie was stick
law tells you, for example,
if a person does x or if x happens,
then y will be the consequence.
It can be complex, it can be
quite specific. If x happens,
why is the consequence? But if x happens
under these different circumstances,
then z is the consequence and it can
be quite detailed giving through your
forced sub-cases with qualifications
at the absolute or APP.
Addictive law by contrast is
an unconditional statement
of a prohibition or a
command. It tends to be general
and somewhat undifferentiated.
You shall not murder you
shall love the Lord your God.
And absolute law at predictive law is
not unknown as a form in other ancient
near eastern cultures,
but it seems to be most characteristically
Israelite find a great deal more of
it in our legal collections in
the Bible than anywhere else.
The provisions of the deck log.
Um,
and again the translation 10 commandments,
it's actually a very poor translation
in the Hebrew is simply means 10
statements, 10 utterances. Um,
these are in the ones that are in some
sort of legal form are in absolute or APP
addictive form.
The deck log is the only part of God's
revelation that is disclosed directly to
all of Israel without an intermediary.
But it's directives are couched
in the masculine singular.
So it seems to be addressing Israelite
males as the lead legal subjects in the
community.
And the deck log sets out some of God's
most basic and unconditional covenant
demands.
The division into 10 is a bit awkward.
It's probably should be
seen as an ideal number,
an effort to find 10 statements in there.
Because in fact there were really about
13 separate statements. And um, we,
we see the fact that 10 doesn't work very
well in a very interesting phenomenon,
which is,
um,
that's so called commandments are actually
numbered differently by Jews and by
Christians. And then even
within the Christian community,
different Christian denominations number
the commandments one through 10 quite
differently from one another.
They disagree about what is number one
and what does number two. And so on.
The first statements,
either one through four,
one through five depending
on your counting,
but the first group of statements
concern Israel's relationship with her,
Susan with God. She used to be
exclusively faithful to God.
She's not to bow down
to any man made image.
She may not use God's
name in a false oath,
right to a test two or
swear by a false oath.
She's to honor God's Sabbath Day
and on our parental authority,
which is arguably an
extension of God's authority.
The remaining statements then concern
Israel's relationship with her fellow
vassals if you will, and they prohibit
murder and adultery and robbery,
false testimony and covetousness.
It's important to realize that the
pentitude contains three versions of the
decalogue and there are
differences among them.
The deck log is going to be repeated in
Deuteronomy chapter five and there are
some minor variations.
Specifically you'll see that the
rationale for observing the sabbath is
different gods name in Deca law in a deck
log and Deuteronomy five is not to be
used in a vein oath as
opposed to a false oath.
There are differences in the meeting and
there are some more differences too in
language.
So what are we to make of this one
scholar Mark Brittler whose name I've
mentioned before,
he says that when we learn from this are
these variations is something about the
way ancient Israel preserved
and transmitted sacred texts.
They didn't strive for
verbatim preservation when
they transmitted biblical
texts and they didn't employ cut and paste
methods that might be important to us
in the transmission of something.
Texts were modified in the course
of their transmission verbatim.
Repetition was not valued in
the way that it might be for us,
so that even a text like the deck,
a log which is represented as
being the unmediated word of God,
can appear in more than one version as
a more surprising variation that occurs.
However,
an exodus 34 after smashing the first
set of tablets that were inscribed with a
deck, a log, um, the deck
log, the tablets in exodus 20,
those are smashed after
the golden calf incident.
Moses is then given a second set of
tablets and the biblical writer emphasizes
in the story at that point that God writes
on the tablets the words that were on
the former tablets that were broken,
the same words.
So we expect now a verbatim repetition
of exodus 20 and yet we don't have it.
The deck,
a log that follows in fact has very
little overlap with the earlier a log.
There's really only two, um, statements
that even have the same content.
And even those which do overlap
in content very in wording,
this deck log,
which is often called the ritual deck log.
So it's listed on there and exodus 34
it bands intermarriage with Canaanites
lest they entice the Israelites into
worship of their gods. It has other terms,
um, that give pro commandments about
the observance of the festivals,
various festivals,
the dedication of first fruits to God,
the dedication of firstborn
animals to God and so on.
Things that were not in
the exodus 20 deck a log.
So evidently there were
different traditions regarding
the contents of the deck,
a log and the story of the golden calf.
And Moses is destruction of the first
set of tablets is brilliant narrative
strategy for introducing this
second deck log tradition.
Also surprising is the fact that the
decalogue and exodus 20 doesn't stand
completely unchallenged in the Bible.
Exodus 20 verses five through six
contain explicitly the principle of
intergenerational punishment.
God has said to spread punishment for
sin out over three or four generations.
This is understood as a sign of his mercy.
It's reducing the punishment on the
actual center by spreading it out and
limiting the consequences to
only three or four generations.
In contrast to what is said in
the next verse. But kindness,
he spreads out over thousands of
generations, right? So it's seen as,
as as a merciful mode of,
of operation.
But the notion of intergenerational
punishment is something that some segments
of the community or perhaps
later in time was rejected.
Some segments of the community have
rejected this notion and so in Deuteronomy
seven we see that quite pointedly,
God punish is only those who spurn
him and does so instantly [inaudible].
When we get to a Zico, we'll see that
he will also very adamantly a reject.
The idea of intergenerational punishment.
The children do not suffer for the
sins of the father, only the father.
So what are we to make of this? Again,
Mark Brittler concludes that the deck,
a log or deck logs did not originally
possess the absolute authority that is so
often claimed for it. Uh, even today,
later religious traditions have
elevated the deck log in exodus 22,
a position of absolute authority,
a position that's not completely justified
given the Bible's own fluid treatment
of the wording, right? The deck
logs text and it's content,
right? And it's later objection
even to one of its terms.
So the claim that God's revelation of
the decalogue was fixed inform the words
that we see in exodus 20,
for example,
and immutable in substance is not a
claim that's really native to or even
justified by the biblical text.
It's a later ideological
imposition upon the text.
I don't want to talk a little
bit more about biblical laws,
connection with the legal
patrimony of the ancient Near East,
because certainly biblical
law shares in that patrimony,
even if sometimes it's clearly reforming.
So it's helpful and it's instructive
to compare it with other ancient law
collections. And I hope you've
had time to sit and read.
There was a study guide posted on the
website and I hope you had time to work
through these materials.
They're fascinating and we'll see that
there are certain key features that
distinguish Israelite law from the other
ancient near eastern legal collections.
I've also put on the handout for today,
just a list of those collections. The,
the laws of or nominally all is the
laws of Lipid Ishtar that laws of
[inaudible] of the code of Hammurabi
which is c h m the Hittite laws. Um,
the,
the youngest laws would be the middle of
Syrian laws giving you rough dates and
so on. So you have that to refer to for
the information about these particular
collections. I should also say that, um,
we would do better to under understand
these materials as legal collections and
not codes. I know the word
code gets thrown around a lot,
code of Hammurabi and so on,
but they really aren't. Codes,
codes are generally
systematic and exhaustive,
and they tend to be used by courts.
We have no evidence about how
these texts were used. In fact,
we think it's not likely that
they were really used by courts,
but they were part of a learned tradition
and scribes copied them over and over
and so on. They are also certainly not
systematic and exhaustive. So for example,
in the quote of homer ropy, we don't
even have a case of intentional homicide.
We only have a case of
accidental homicide.
So we really don't even
know what the law would be.
In a case of intentional homicide,
we can't really make that
comparison with the biblical law.
Now in a very important article that was
written nearly half a century ago now,
it's hard to believe, um, by a
man named Moshe Greenberg. Um,
he's a biblical scholar and
he argued that a comparison,
a biblical law with other ancient near
eastern collection reveals the central
postulates or values that
undergird biblical law. Uh,
I'll be drawing extensively on Greenberg's
work in this presentation as well as
other scholars who have
picked up some of his ideas.
And I've taken them in other directions.
So,
but it was really Greenberg who was the
one who I think made the first foray
into this kind of comparative approach.
And since then others have have
taken advantage of that idea. Um,
there is Greenburg says and immediate
and critically important difference
between ancient,
ancient near eastern collections and the
Israelite laws as they're presented by
the biblical narrator. And that's a
difference in authorship. So if you look,
for example, at the prologue to
the laws of war Namo on an end,
little gave kingship to or not,
but or Namu is said to
establish equity and the laws,
if you look at Liquid Ishtar,
the both the prologue and
the epilogue on and legal,
the gods give kingship
to liberty each star.
But Lipid Ishtar establishes justice to
be first and the laws as my handiwork
and the first person or the prologue
to the code of Hammurabi again, laugh,
Deon Newman and end lil established
for him and enduring kingdom,
they name him to promote the welfare
of the people cause justice to prevail.
When Marduk commissioned me to direct
the land and now it switches into first
person speech. I established law and
justice in the language of the land.
At that time I decreed
the laws of justice.
The law is that the efficient
King Hammurabi set up.
I wrote my precious words on my stele,
which you can go and see it.
Sterling Memorial Library. Um, and
in the presence of the statue of me,
the king of justice, I set it up in
order to administer the law of the land,
to prescribe the ordinances of the land,
to give justice to the oppressed.
And we first do it is my justice,
my statutes,
no one should we send them my
scribes, delay my precious words, um,
do not alter the law of the land
which I enacted I AI throughout. Um,
by contrast in Biblical law,
authorship is not ascribed to Moses ever.
It is attributed always to God.
So you see an exodus 24 verses three
and four Moses went and repeated to the
people,
all the commands of the Lord and all the
rules and all the people answered with
one voice. All that the Lord has
commanded, we will obey and do.
Moses then wrote down all
the commands of the Lord.
It's the repetition makes you feel
that the biblical writer here is not
accidentally saying these things,
trying to drive home a very strong point.
Exodus 31 18 when he got finished speaking
with him on Mount Sinai with Moses on
Mount Sinai,
he gave Moses the two tablets of the
pact stone tablets inscribed with the
finger of God.
So Greenburg and since him rettler
and many others have argued that the
principle of divine authorship has
certain very important implications.
First,
it has a significant effect on the scope
of the law in ancient near eastern and
Biblical law differ concerning the areas
of human life and activity that fall
within the concern of the law.
It doesn't mean they don't fall
within the concern of humanity.
They just fall within
the concern of the law.
That's an ideal come back to in a minute
is relight law will contain more than
just rules and provisions that fall
within the scope of the coercive power of
the state to enforce,
right?
More than what would fall under the
jurisdiction of law. Courts, for example,
or illegal decides source. It is holistic.
The scope of the law is holistic.
It's going to contain social and ethical
and moral and religious prescriptions
and very often they're going to be
couched in an authoritative app,
addictive style,
particularly the things that aren't
enforceable in a court of law.
They will tend to be the ones that
are backed up by the authority of God
directly. You shall do this,
I the Lord am your God.
Notice how many times that that refrain
is used and it's almost always used with
those unenforceable kinds of things.
Love your neighbor as yourself.
You know I the Lord your God.
It's me who's watching out for this one,
not the court.
Okay.
The extra biblical law collections deal
almost exclusively with matters that are
enforceable by the state.
That doesn't necessarily mean they were.
We don't know how these were used,
but they don't tend to deal
with matters that we would call,
we would call it matters of
conscience or moral rectitude.
So you'd be very hard pressed in the
extra biblical collections to find a law
like exodus 23 verses four and five when
you encounter your enemies ox or ass
wandering,
you must take it back to him.
When you see the ass of your enemy lying
under its burden and you would refrain
from raising it,
you must nevertheless raise it with him
or Leviticus 19 verses 17 and 18 you
shall not hate your
kinsfolk in your heart.
You imagined congress
passing a law like that.
You shall not hate your kinsfolk in
your heart. Reprove your kinsmen,
but incurred no guilt because of him and
don't carry around a grudge. Reproof.
I'm tell him what's wrong. Clear the
air. Don't carry around a grudge.
You shall not take vengeance or bear
a grudge against your countrymen.
Love Yourself, love your fellow
as yourself. I am the Lord, right?
That refrain always comes after
those kinds of statements.
So the Bible includes norms for human
behavior set by the divine will,
even though enforcement has to be left
to the individual conscience and in the
tour. Therefore life is treated
holistically in the realm of law.
One's actions aren't compartmentalized,
and that's why the legal materials
to us can sometimes seem like an
indiscriminate mix of laws
concerning all areas of life.
And it's one of the things that makes
people confused because a lot of moderns
have gotten the idea that the Bible
only deals with what we call morality.
And so they don't understand all this
other stuff that's in there, right?
And sometimes if we tell ourselves,
well, this is illegal collection,
then we don't understand why there's
all this moral looking stuff in there.
It is a mixture because it's holistic.
It is the will of God and God has
something to say about all areas of life.
And so in exodus 23 you're going to have
a law that's tells you not to oppress a
stranger because you were a stranger.
It tells you to not plow your land in
the sabbath year immediately following
that to let the poor
and needy eat from it.
It tells you to observe the Sabbath Day.
Rest,
you shall not mention any other gods.
Um,
it tells you how to observe the three
pilgrimage festivals and rules of ritual
offering.
And then there are also civil laws.
Same thing in Leviticus 18 through 20.
We have incest laws, we have ritual laws,
we have civil laws, and we have
moral laws altogether. Now,
a second implication,
right?
Another idea that flows from the fact
that this law is, is divinely authored.
So second implication of divine
authorship according to Greenberg,
is this connection
between law and morality.
So that in the biblical legal framework,
every crime is also a sin.
Every crime is also a sin.
Law is the moral will of God,
and nothing is beyond
the moral will of God.
So what's illegal is also immoral
and vice versa. What's immoral?
It's also illegal.
Law and morality are not separate.
As we moderns tend to think they are
an ought to be right in our society.
Offenses against morality. In the biblical
world are also religious offenses.
There are also sins because they
are infractions of the divine will.
So the fusion of morality
and Law Greenberger I use
is the reason that biblical
law not only expresses,
but legislates a concern for the
unfortunate members of society.
For example, orphans, strangers, widows,
as well as respect for the aged from the
priestly sources is Leviticus 19 verse
32 we read you shall rise before the
aged and show deference to the old you
shall fear your God. I am the Lord. Yeah,
I refrain always has to come with us.
Kind of a statement.
The extra biblical codes certainly exhibit
concern for the rights of the poor.
This is very important,
particularly in their prologues.
We read some of these prologues, you know,
I, my desire was to help the orphans,
the strangers and so on. Um,
but when you look at the,
the content of the laws as in our society,
they don't legislate charity.
They don't legislate compassion,
compassion.
It's likely that these were considered
acts of who knows, personal conscience,
religious convictions,
something that was between the
individual and society and their God,
I don't know, but they were outside the
domain and jurisdiction of the court.
That doesn't mean that charity
and compassion we're not at,
we're not present in other
ancient near eastern cultures.
The point is that law is not understood
as being the appropriate vehicle for the
expression of those values.
There were other sorts of texts that
might do those sorts of things and urge
people to charity and compassion.
But law legislation is not understood
to be the appropriate vehicle for the
expression of those values. So again, I'm,
I'm not trying to say the ancient
near eastern side. Everybody was mean.
I'm starting to say that the law,
because of its done,
divine authorship
suddenly takes on a scope,
a holistic scope and a fusion of law
and morality that are kept separate in
other cultures in it and very
much in our own right. Um,
so the two,
however,
our combined and law is understood to
be the appropriate vehicle to legislate
compassion,
for example.
So in Leviticus 19 nine
verse 10 legislating charity.
When you reap the harvest of your land,
you shall not reap all the way to
the edges of your field or gather the
gleanings of your harvest.
You shall not pick your vineyard,
bear or gather the fallen
fruit of your vineyard.
You shall leave them for the poor and the
stranger. I The Lord am your God. Again,
from the holiness code live,
it gets 1914 you shall not insult the
death or place a stumbling block before
the blind. You shall fear
your God. I am the Lord again.
Always has to back it up because this
is not something the courts can backup,
right?
This is a question of your morality or
Leviticus 20 verse 18 love your fellow as
yourself.
I am the Lord.
Leviticus 19 verses 33 to 34 when a
stranger resides with you and your land,
you shall not wrong him.
The Stranger who resides with you shall
be to you as one of your citizens.
You shall love him as yourself. For you
were strangers in the land of Egypt.
I The Lord am your God.
Deuteronomy 22 six if along the road you
chance upon a bird's nest in any tree
or on the ground with fledglings or
eggs and the mother sitting over the
fledglings are on the eggs, do not take
the mother together with her young.
Let the mother go and take only the
young in order that you may fare well and
have a long life, meaning God
will reward you. So again,
this is enforceable by God.
Furthermore,
Greenberg argues that the fact that
every crime is also a sin lays the ground
for certain acts to be viewed
as absolutely wrong and
transcending the power of
humans to forgive absolutely wrong,
and they transcend the power of humans to
pardon or forgive. Take for an example,
adultery.
Deuteronomy 2122 if Amanda's found
lying with another man's wife,
both of them, the man and the
woman with whom he lays shall die.
Thus you shall sweep away evil from
Israel and murder is the other one.
Number's 35 verse 16 the
murderer must be put to death.
You may not accept a ransom
for the life of a murderer.
This is now verse 31 who is
guilty of a capital crime.
He must be put to death in
the view of the biblical text.
Adultery and murder are absolutely wrong.
They must always be punished regardless
of the attitude of the offended parties.
All right, so a husband can
say, oh, that's okay. I don't
want to punish my white.
Let them have their fun. It's no
big deal. I don't mind. All right,
and the family of a murder of victor
can't murder victim can't say, you know,
Joe was such a pain in the neck anyway.
You've really done us a favor. You know,
just pay the funeral costs. We'll call
it quits. You know, you can't do that.
These are absolutely wrong.
These deeds as infractions
of God's will and God's law,
they're always wrong.
They transcend the power of human
parties to pardon or forgive or excuse,
and you compare that with the extra
biblical collections and you see quite a
difference in the code of Hammurabi
number at one 29 adults rate.
These are adultery is considered a
private affair. If the wife of his senior,
I have to,
this terminology is just wonderful senor.
This comes I think from um,
French feudalism.
These have to do with class distinctions.
And so the translators of this particular
translation, a chose these futile,
very meaningful to you.
I'm sure these futile categories.
Essentially what's going on here
is the underlying Acadian words,
I guess are we alone? Moosh, Ghanem
and then a third category slave.
When the three,
when they appear together,
IBM tends to refer to an upper class
person and which came to a common,
or having them can just
mean an ordinary citizen.
But when it's in juxtaposition
with the other terms,
it's clearly someone of a higher social
class. So I will, we'll use aristocrat,
which is where we get the French feudal
senor and then we'll use common or and
slave. So when the code of Hammurabi
and the wife, if the wife of a,
a citizen has been caught
while lying with another man,
they shall bind them and
throw them into the water.
But if the husband of the
woman wishes to spare his wife,
then the king and turn may spare
his subject. It's up to the husband.
He is the offended party.
It's a private matter.
He decides the middle of Syrian laws
on tablet a numbers 14 to 16. Again,
it's a crime against the
property of the husband.
And so it's within his power
to either prosecute or not.
If a senior and I'll be loom has
lane with the wife of another,
either in a temple bravo or in the street
knowingly knowing that she was a wife,
then they shall treat the adulterer as
the senior orders his wife to be treated.
Okay. So whatever he does to hurt, they
do the same thing to the, to the mail.
But if he was innocent, he didn't
know that she was a married woman.
The senor shell prosecute
his wife, treating her as he
thinks fit. It's up to him.
If the woman's husband, um, this more
ifs and dens. But here's the case,
that if the woman's husband put him,
puts his wife to death,
he shall also put this in your to death.
But if he cuts off his wife's,
knows he shall turn this in,
you are into a unit and I guess this
is considered equivalent and they shall
mutilate his whole face. However,
if he let his wife go free,
they shall let the Senor
Goffrey. All right. Again,
it's a private matter and
the Hittite laws as well,
tablet to one 97 to one 98 the husband
can decide to spare his wife if he brings
them to the gate of the palace and
declares my wife shall not be killed and
thereby spares his wife's life.
He shall also spare the life of the
adulterer and shall mark his head.
But if he says, let them die, both of
them, then the king may order them killed,
but also the king can spare their lives.
All right,
and we see the same sorts of
distinctions in murder cases. We'll,
we'll come back to them later.
A third implication or consequence of
the divine authorship of biblical law
according to Greenberg,
is that the purpose of the law in
Israelite Society is going to be different
from the purpose of the law in other
societies. So in Non Israelite Society,
the purpose of the law is um,
to secure certain sociopolitical benefits.
Um, think about the preamble
of the American constitution,
which states the purpose of the law.
It reads almost exactly like the
prologues to these ancient collections.
You can pick out words that are identical.
The purpose of the law is to establish
justice, insure domestic tranquility,
provide for the common defense,
promote the general welfare and
secure the blessings of liberty.
So when you see the prologue of
board anomal the purpose of the law,
established equity,
protect the underprivileged,
promote the common wheel and welfare.
Basically loss of liberty star in
the prologue. Established justice.
Banish complaints. I like
that one. Bring wellbeing,
promote the common wheel and welfare.
Same again with the quote of Hama.
Robbie's a prologue to promote the
welfare of the people. Good government,
the right way prosperity.
But for Israel, the law is,
it does include these benefits but
is not limited to these benefits.
The law also aims at sanctifying.
All right.
A concept we dealt with at great
length in the last lecture,
sanctifying rendering holy or like God,
those who abide by its terms.
So the laws that are presented in the
holiness code are introduced with this
exhortation which you don't
find in other places. Uh,
Leviticus 19 verse two you shall
be holy for I the Lord your God,
am holy and then the laws began. You
shall eat, revere your mother and father,
keep my sabbaths, et Cetera, et
cetera. But the introduction,
you shall be holy for I the Lord your God,
am Holy.
Being wholly in imitation of
God is emphasized repeatedly
as the purpose of the
laws in the holiness code,
especially the holiness Motif is
represented as being present at the very
inception of the covenant when when
Israel is assembled at Mount Sinai,
that opening speech that God makes an
exodus 19 verse five and six now then if
you obey me faithfully and
keep my covenant, keep my laws,
you shall be my treasured possession
among all the peoples. Indeed,
all the earth is mine,
but you shall be to me a kingdom
of priests and a holy nation.
These are the rules that Deema market
you as dedicated to me, I, he holy.
Now,
there are lots of general and specific
similarities and parallels between
Israelite and ancient near eastern laws,
lots of goring oxen,
lots of pregnant women who are in the
wrong place at the wrong time and getting
struck and accidentally miscarrying.
Um,
but we're going to look at some of the
formal and stylistic differences between
ancient near eastern and Biblical law.
And we can assume just a tremendous
amount of common ground. Okay.
And some of these are pointed out by
Greenburg and some by other scholars,
but I've listed them there under features.
One distinguishing feature of his
Israelite law is the addition of, um,
a rationale or a motive clause in many
of the laws. All right? Which again,
is not something that's really a featured
in the genre of law writing in these
other collections.
It's not a part of the genre of writing.
Those doesn't mean that he
didn't have a rationale,
but it wasn't how it was presented.
So we find this in the Bible,
particularly in what we might refer
to as the, as the humanitarian laws.
And on the whole,
these rationales will appeal to historical
events like the exodus or creation.
You're a few laws that express the
idea that the experience of slavery,
slavery, and liberation should be
the wellspring for moral action.
It should be the impetus for moral action.
Exodus 2120.
You shall not wrong a stranger or oppress
him for you were strangers in the land
of Egypt.
23,
nine you shall not oppress a stranger for
you know the feelings of the stranger.
Having yourself, yourselves been
strangers in the land of Egypt.
And Leviticus 19 contains
a similar x rotation.
Not to wrong a stranger
who resides with you,
but love him as yourself for you
were strangers in the land of Egypt.
Likewise in Deuteronomy five,
this is the deck log and Deuteronomy,
um,
which is talking about Sabbath observance
and ensuring that all in your abode
rest you, your son, your daughter, your
male or female slave, your ox, your ass,
or any of your cattle and the
stranger and your settlements.
So that your male and female slave may
rest is you do remember that you were a
slave in the land of Egypt. And the
Lord God freed you from there. Um,
also for the Lord your God has God
supreme and Lord Supreme, the great,
the mighty and the awesome God who
shows no favor and takes no bride.
Bribe takes no bride also but takes
no bribe but upholds the cause of the
fatherless and the widow and befriends
the stranger providing him with food and
clothing. So you two must
have a friend, a stranger,
you were strangers in the land of Egypt.
We have two rationales there.
One is the explicit rationale.
If imma Tatsuo Day,
this is what I do and this is
what you should do. Um, and, and,
and there are more many of them referring
to the exodus and Egypt and others
referring to the notion of imitates CEO d.
So it's awesome,
illuminating to compare,
um,
the ancient near eastern and the
biblical legal materials in terms of, um,
the concern for the disadvantaged,
the elimination of,
of social class distinctions and
a trend towards humanitarianism.
Greenburg notes that the Torah is concern
for the disadvantage of society is
quite marked in the
actual laws themselves.
Many of the extra biblical
legal collections pay homage
to this idea and they're
prologues doesn't always seem
to be appearing. However,
in the actual terms of these collections,
now these collections are incomplete.
We don't have everything.
And again,
it may be another literary genre that
accomplished some of that work in that
culture, the Torah laws, um, and that, oh,
and also the laws in those collections,
very often,
despite the prologues rhetoric that they
bring justice to the disadvantaged and
so on. Many of the laws clearly served
the interests of an upper class. Okay.
That's the more important part point.
They clearly serve the
interest of an upper class.
The Torah laws do not contain all the
same distinctions of social class among
free persons as the contemporary laws,
the laws of Vishnu motion,
the laws of Hammurabi.
These laws distinguish between punishments
for crimes committed against upper
class and lower class person's
not to mention slaves.
So if we look at the code of Hammurabi,
there's a stretch of, of um, laws.
Number one,
nine one 95 to up to eight something.
Um, and they're, they're very
interesting to read them all in a row.
I'll hit some highlights. So
if an upper class person, okay,
and if an aristocrat has destroyed the,
I have a member of the aristocracy,
they destroy his eye. If he breaks
his bone, they break his bone.
But as you move down to one 98,
if he destroys the high of a commoner
or breaks the bone of a commoner,
a commoner, he pays one Mina
of silver. And if it's a slave,
he pays half the value of the slave
onto 200 and 201 if he knocks out and
aristocrats tooth, they knock out his
tooth. But if it's a commoners tooth,
he pays a third of a mean of silver.
And so on the Hittite laws too,
they are different. There are
different amounts fixed by class.
In the miscarriage laws,
95 and 99,
the middle of Syrian laws also
distinguished between the hour.
We learned the Mooc Kanombe in the slave.
Uh,
Leviticus 24 verses 17 to 22,
we have their laws of personal liability,
bodily injury,
assault and battery or bodily injury.
And we find a clear and explicit statement
to the effect that there shall be one
standard for citizen and stranger alike.
This is known as the principal
of Talon Lex Talionis.
So reading from Leviticus,
if anyone names his fellow,
if anyone names his fellow as he
has done so shall it be done to him?
Fracture for fracture, eye
for eye, tooth for tooth,
the injury he inflicted on
another shall be inflicted on him.
You shall have one standard for
stranger and citizens alike.
For I the Lord am your God.
This was a radical concept and its day.
Evidently the punishment should fit the
crime no more and no less for all free
persons.
Granted,
slaves are not included regardless of
social class equality before the law and
this cast the principle of Italian, I
hope in a new light, the law of Italian,
which is essentially the principle that
a person should be punished according to
the injury they inflicted.
It's been decried as a primitive,
archaic reflex of the vengeance
or vendetta principle.
The notion of an eye for an eye,
it's usually cited,
are held up as typical of the harsh
and cruel standards of the uh,
vengeful Old Testament God. But when
you look at it in a comparative light,
in its legal context,
we see that it's a polemic against the
class distinctions that were being drawn
in antecedent and contemporary legal
systems such as the code of homer ropy.
According to the Bible,
the punishment should always fit the
crime regardless of the social status of
the perpetrator on the one hand
or the victim on the other.
All free citizens who injure are
treated equally before the law.
They're neither led off lightly
nor punished excessively.
If you read the middle of Syrian laws,
don't want to do that on an empty stomach,
a 20 a 21 and f one, you have multiple
punishments that are carried out.
Someone who causes a miscarriage,
they have a monetary fine,
they have to pay to talents and 30
meters of led their flogged 50 times,
and then they have to do curvey forced
labor for the state for a month.
Multiple punishments for sheep stealing.
That's even worse if flogged a hundred
times and they pull out your hair and
there's a monetary fine and you do
curvey forced labor for a month.
So are these ideas,
is this idea that the punishment should
be neither too little, nor too much?
It should match the crime that all
free persons are equal before the law.
That one standard should apply
regardless of the social status of the
perpetrator or the victim. These
ideas really primitive legal concepts.
In addition to asserting the
basic equality before the
law for all free citizens,
the Bible mandates concern
for the disenfranchised.
We've already seen that a little bit and
the laws of Leviticus 19 verses nine to
10 which says that you have to leave.
Do you know,
don't go over your fields picking
every little last bit. You know,
just go through,
give it you need,
but leave a little bit behind and let
the poor and the stranger glean their
Deuteronomy is a little less generous.
They substitute for the substitute.
The phrase the widow, the orphan, and
the stranger in that law were Leviticus,
says the poor. Uh, Deuteronomy
24 verses 20 to 22,
when you beat down the fruit of your
olive trees or gather the Grapes of your
vineyard,
do not go over them again.
That which remains on the tree shall go
to the stranger and the orphan and the
widow always remember, you are a
slave in the land of Egypt. Therefore,
do I enjoy new to
observe this commandment?
So Leviticus supports outright charity
for the poor in the form of gleanings
kind of a welfare system. Deuteronomy
has more of a work fair system in mind.
They actually never mentioned the poor.
It's only Leviticus that mentions
the poor. Uh, for Deuteronomy,
it's the those who really can't provide
for themselves. I'm the widow, the orphan,
and the stranger who,
who may not be able to find employment.
The poor should be working,
but you can assist them
with loans according to
Deuteronomy and these should be
generous.
Here's Deuteronomy is admonition to
loan money to the poor even if it means
potential loss to yourself because
the seventh year is imminent.
The sabbatical year in the sabbatical
year, all debts were released, canceled,
okay. Sort of a economic corrective to
restore people to a more equal economic
situation. So in the sixth
years, some people will feel,
I don't really want to lend money and
it's going to be canceled next year I
won't get my money back. Loans must be
made even if the debt will be canceled.
For the simple reason that the problem
of poverty is a terrible and persistent
problem. Deuteronomy 15 verses
seven through 11 if there
is among you a poor man,
one of your brethren,
you shall not harden your heart or shut
your hand against your poor brethren,
but you shall open your hand to him
and lend him sufficient for his need,
whatever it may be. Beware,
lest you harbor the base
thought woo. The seventh year,
the year of debt releases approaching so
that you are mean to your poor kinsmen
and give him nothing you shall give to
him freely and your heart shall not be
grudging when you give to him for the
poor will never cease out of the land,
right? The poor will always be with
you. This is where it comes from,
but it gets misquoted later.
Um, it's taken to me in the
poor are always with you,
so you don't have to do anything. It's
not what it means here in Deuteronomy.
Lend to them because the poor will
never see side of the land. Therefore,
I command you, open wide your
hand, get busy, give charity.
It's a problem that never goes away
so you can never rest connected with.
This is the biblical trend
towards humanitarianism.
And there is of course,
much in biblical legislation that
offends modern sensibilities.
There's no point in pretending
that there isn't. For example,
as in the rest of the ancient world,
slavery existed in Israel.
It did even so,
and this is not to apologize for it.
There is a tendency toward humanitarianism
in the laws concerning slavery.
The Bible's equivocating
on this institution. Um,
some societies in their legal systems,
it's clear that slaves are the chattel,
the property of the master. The Bible,
again, equivocates on this question,
they affirm some personal rights
for the slave, but not all. Uh,
in contrast to,
for example,
the middle of Syrian laws were a
master can kill a slave with impunity.
The Bible legislates that the master
who wounds his slave in any way,
even losing a tooth,
which is understood to be a minor thing
because it's not in any way in a central
Oregon. So even if he knocks out a
tooth, right, uh, he has to set him free.
That's an exodus 21 verses 26 to 27.
Moreover,
the slave is entitled to the Sabbath
Rest in all of the sabbath legislation.
And quite importantly, a fugitive slave
cannot be returned to its his master.
That's in Deuteronomy
three verses 16 to 17.
You shall not turn over to his master,
a slave who seeks refuge
with you from his master.
He shall live with you in any place.
He may choose among the settlements
in your midst, wherever he pleases,
you must not ill treat him. This is
the opposite of the fugitive slave law,
actually in this country in
the 19th century, but also
in Hammurabi's code, right?
I'm Ravi is code 1516 through 19 if
a citizen has harbored in his house,
either a fugitive male or female slave
belonging to the state or a private
citizen and has not brought him
forth at the summons of the police,
that householder shall be put to death.
The term of Israelite Israelite slavery.
That is to say an Israelite who has
fallen into service to another Israelite
through generally indebtedness. That's,
that's a form that's slavery took in the,
in the ancient world and
in the biblical picture,
the term was limited
to six years by exodus,
by the covenant code and the Priestly
Code. It's prohibited altogether.
No Israelite can be a
slave to another Israelite,
so it's actually done away with as an
institution altogether. In general,
the Bible urges humanitarian
treatment of the slave.
Again for you were once slaves
in Egypt is the refrain.
Other evidence of the trend towards
humanitarianism is the lack of legalized
violence in the Bible here,
if you compare the middle of Syrian law
is you'll see something quite different
there.
The middle of Syrian loss
explicitly authorize inhumane
treatment of a deserting
wife. You can cut off her
ears, um, legalized violence.
In the case of a disc trainee.
A dis trainee is a pledge,
someone who has been placed in your house
because of a debt and is working for
you. Um, the, the citizen
may do what he wishes, um,
as he feels the dis strain he
deserves and he pull out his hair,
he made mutilate his ears by piercing
them. I'm in the middle of Syrian laws,
also legalized violence against
a wife when she deserves it.
A Senor may pull out the hair of his wife,
mutilate or twist her ears.
There's no liability attaching to him.
Legal systems often express their values
by the punishments that are positive
for various transgressions.
And here,
Moshe Greenberg has done something very
interesting, a little controversial.
Not everyone agrees with this,
but he's pointed out that
the Bible differs from the
other extra biblical codes
in the value that it places on human life.
And you consider the crimes that are
punished by capital punishment and the
crimes that are punished
by monetary compensation.
And he feels this is quite revealing.
So I've put this very handy little chart
on the board for you listing codes on
one side and you'll see the kinds of
things that are punished by monetary fine
or compensation. In the
Hittite laws. Homicide,
you pay a certain amount of money
to compensate for the desk, right?
Um, personal injury, bodily injury,
you pay a certain amount of money, um,
in the middle of Syria and laws also
homicide. It's up to the family.
They'd can decide how they want this to
be punished, but they can take money.
Quote of Hama ropy we only
have accidental homicide case.
We don't have an intentional
homicide cases and we don't know,
but bodily injury when it's between equals
than the principle of Italian applies.
But when it's not between equals
monetary payment as cell on death.
On the other hand is um,
is the punishment for certain property
crimes instead of personal injury and
homicide crimes,
death for theft in the Hittite
laws and for bestie reality.
I'm in the middle of Syrian laws also
theft and in the code of Hammurabi,
theft and cheating. I'll go over some
of these in a little more detail.
So Greenburg is going to argue that the
Bible reverses the view of the other
codes and he says because in those life
is cheap and property is highly valued.
So Hammurabi's code imposes the death
penalty for the theft of property for
assisting in the escape of a slave,
which is it's master's property for
cheating a customer over the price of a
drink.
Middle of Syrian laws,
there's death to a wife if she steals
from her husband and death to any who
purchased the stolen goods.
The Bible never imposes his death penalty
for violations of property rights,
personal property rights,
private property rights, um,
only for intentional homicide and
certain religious and sexual offenses,
which are seem to be
direct defenses to God.
Greenburg argues that in so doing the
Bible is expressing the view that the
sanctity of human life is
paramount in its value system.
The Bible states explicitly that
homicide is the one crime for which note
monetary punishment can be substituted.
You cannot ransom the life of a murderer.
He must pay with his life numbers.
35 31 to 34.
You may not accept a ransom for the
life of a murderer who is guilty of a
capital crime.
He must be put to death,
nor may you accept ransom in place of
flight to a city of refuge. Remember,
if it's an accidental homicide,
there is the lenient seen in the law
that that person can run to a city of
refuge and remain there until the
death of the high priest. His,
the shedding of his blood purchased
the land of blood guilt, if you will,
because this is a religious
crime. Um, and you can't, but you,
he can't pay money instead of running
to the city of refuge. Um, and, uh,
you shall not pollute the
land in which you live.
There's a notion here of blood guilt
of pollution. Blood pollutes the land,
and the land can have no expiation
for blood that is shed on it,
except by the blood of Him who shed it.
You shall not defile the land in which
you live. In which I myself abide for.
I The Lord abide among the Israelite
people and outside the Bible,
we'd really don't have that absolute
ban on monetary compensation for murder.
And Greenberg has argued that
for the biblical legislators,
human life and property are
simply incommensurable crimes.
And the one realm cannot be compensated
by punishment. In the other realm,
a crime in the realm of of life personal
injury has to be compensated in the
same realm. In the same way, property
crimes are not punished by death.
Also in the Bible, there is no
what I call literal punishment.
You'll sometimes see people refer
to this as vicarious punishment.
I don't think it's vicarious punishment.
I call it literal punishment.
Little punishment. For example, in
the code of homer ropy where, um,
someone's ox kills a child,
um,
then the ox child is killed.
That's not vicarious.
You're not substituting. It's literal.
The the legal subject is the father.
He has lost a child. So I have to suffer
the literal punishment as a father,
I have to lose my child,
right? It's not a substitution.
It's a literal punishment for
what you did to the other.
And the Bible explicitly rejects
that idea. In exodus 21, um,
and explicitly says that the owner's
child is not to be put to death,
is not killed.
Deuteronomy 24,
16 states that parents shall not be put
to death for children or children be put
to death for their parents.
A person shall be put to
death only for his own crime.
The equal value of human life and limb
is also protected by the principle of
tallying that we discussed
above in the quote of Hama,
ropy and Aristocrat can simply pay
money for injuring an inferior.
That's not going to be much of
a hardship to a wealthy person.
And it certainly reflects the low value
that's placed on the life and limb of a
member of the lower class.
[inaudible] only applies between
social equals in the code of Hammurabi.
But in the Bible,
the extension of Townie and all
free persons regardless of class,
expresses the notion that all
persons are of equal value.
In the case of rape,
the rapists wife is not rate as happens
in the middle of Syrian laws. Again,
a literal punishment.
Other biblical values are reflected in
the emphasis on laws that deal with the
plight of the poor, the slave, the
alien, the rights and dignity of debtors.
And so on. Reach just about the end of
my time. Just one last statement. Um,
because I don't want to leave you
with the impression that the biblical
materials speak with one
voice. They don't, I mean,
Greenberg has tried to pull
out some, some common, um, uh,
values.
Biblical legal materials
contain provisions that
contradict one another later
versions of the law,
particularly in d for example,
we'll update and revise earlier versions
of the law. And I love it. It gets,
takes issue with the whole
institution of Israelites,
slavery that's accepted in the covenant
quote. And in Deuteronomy it says,
it's just, no, it can't happen. You can't
be all Israelites are servants of God.
None of you can be servants to another.
All right, so these, these laws had,
there's contradiction.
Nevertheless,
I think what Greenberg is trying to
say is that it is still fair. Um,
even though the materials
are contain contradictions,
it's still fair to say that they
sound certain common themes,
a express certain important principles
and values which include the supreme
sanctity of human life that's pretty
consistently maintained among the codes.
The value of persons over property pretty
consistently maintained the equality
of all free persons before the
law consistently maintained.
The importance of assisting the
disadvantaged in society very consistently
maintained.
Um,
the integration and the interdependence
of all aspects of human life all coming
within the will of God to legislate
very consistently maintained.
We come back on Monday.
I just want to say a little bit about
the narrative context in which the laws
are found before we move
on into Deuteronomy.
Monday evening will be the time at which
the midterm exam will be posted on the
website and that'll be at
6:00 PM Monday evening.
You'll have a 24 hour period of time
in which to find, I forget what I said,
30 or 40 minutes.
It'll be clear on the instructions to
just sit and treat it as if you're in an
in class exam situation.
Write your essay.